using the beast director bill condon did
a great job adapting Disney's classic
animation into a live-action movie but
during the editing process some
intriguing moments got cursed including
some funny battle scenes in the castle
and a very different take on the song
days in the Sun yippie Kay movie lovers
it's Jan here and with the blu-ray of
Beauty and the Beast out now I'm going
to break down all the official deleted
scenes and discuss the many Easter eggs
and callbacks to the original animated
movie as well as other details we never
got to see in the theatrical release I'm
also starting a new giveaway on this
video for a chance to win this gorgeous
hardback book tale as old as time the
art of making a Beauty and the Beast
just subscribe and leave a comment about
the movie and also make sure you answer
the question I'll be asking later in the
video
by the way obviously there are spoilers
ahead if you haven't seen the movie
during the battle between the enchanted
objects and the villagers at the beasts
castle there's a funny little moment
that was cut with the village lasses the
scene shows the last is armed with
pitchforks chasing chip and frou-frou
through the castle and into the kitchen
which is work within years a castle chef
turned stove covers them in treacle and
feathers and they run off screaming this
scene is actually a lovely call back to
the original animated movie world of foo
and two other members assorted weaponry
race after the castles enchanted
footstool who stolen one of the food
shoes until they're threatened away by
the kitchens fiery stove also deleted
from the battle at the castle is a scene
where Lumia is attacked by one of the
female villagers and cosworth comes to
his friends rescue sliding down the
banister and shooting the villager in
the bus however when she turns around
Cogsworth is shocked to find the person
he shot is Clothilde now if you remember
at the end of the film when the
enchanted objects turn back into human
servants we discover that Clothilde has
actually Cogsworth wife and that he's
definitely not happy to be reunited with
her which explains why in this deleted
scene Cogsworth continued to fight her
off with a sword even after he knows who
she is
again this deleted scene is a delightful
throwback to the original animation
where Cogsworth Satan whom we have been
being melted by the food in that
animated scene Cogsworth chooses between
a pistol and a pair of scissors and
comes barreling down the banister
stabbing the foo in the butt with the
scissors using them like a sword
in the final live-action film plumet
strikes Lefou in the faith with her
feathers but we don't see what happens
next the section cut from the movie
after that shows the food rushing after
Polly met and catching her in a net
however Lumiere comes to her rescue when
he uses his candles to burn the foods
but in the animated classic it's not
less food but one of the other villagers
who's mistreating the enchanted duster
by plucking out her feathers but again
Lumiere saves the day by torching the
villagers behind during the mob scene at
the castle the foo continues to question
his allegiance to Gaston and in a
humorous deleted scene he hides away
from the fighting in one of the castles
many rooms unfortunately for the foo the
room he picks is an enchanted bathroom
where a new character called Monsieur
toilette drench at him with water which
sends Lefou rushing off screaming then
at the end of the film when the
household objects transform back into
human beings there's another deleted
scene where actor Stephen Merchant
appears playing mr. toilette just
standing there
clothes wet and dirty mouth the gate
basically completely horrified by what
you've been through during the curse
when the few arrives he identifies
Monsieur toilette due to the terrible
odor and asked him what he's going to do
now to which he replies brush my teeth
and if you're wondering why all these
little moments I've been talking about
so far were cut from the end movie it
was really a question of both timing and
taste as according to director Bill
Condon the movie was running long and so
the humor was considered a bit lowbrow
in comparison to the rest of the film
there a similar expand the mob song in
the live-action film compared to the
animated movie the missing section would
have fit into the film
just after Gaston consults the beasts
magic mirror to check where the castle
is and it features the villagers making
their way through the woods while
singing the lines we don't like what we
don't understand
in fact it scares us and this monster is
mysterious at least bring your guns
bring your knives take your children and
your wives we'll save our village and
our lives we'll kill the Beast then
straight after those words the deleted
scene shows the villagers breaking down
the ice gates that lead up to the castle
this shot of the village is storming
through the broken gates is beautiful
and kind of symbolic and it looks like
they're walking through the jaws would
be
I can see why bill condom was sad to cut
the scene so he did so I D was aware of
the films running time and also felt it
downplayed the tension of the moment the
scene that was cut from the movies
opening section shows Bell giving the
beggar woman a guitar some bread and jam
which is very grateful for it's just a
small moment between these two
characters who we don't see interact
during the final film and it highlights
Bell's kind and compassionate nature and
also emphasizes how different she is
from the other villagers who treat
Agatha unkindly like an outsider and on
top of that this deleted scene may also
go some way to answering the question of
what happened to the baguette that Belle
bought from the Baker which was in her
dress pocket during the opening song one
minutes that mysteriously disappeared
the next it would have been nice to see
a bit more of Agatha in the movie
because a character is rather important
after all she is the Enchantress in
disguise
and if you'd like to learn more about
the secrets of The Enchantress in this
movie then check out my video on that
very subject by tapping in the top right
of the screen after the townspeople
throw Belle's soaking wet clothes all
over the ground because they don't like
her new laundry cleaning invention the
scene that was cut from the film which
shows Gaston arriving blasting his guns
with a crowd to make way and telling
them they're behaving badly and should
go home while this may seem on the
surface like a decent thing to do as
usual Gaston has his own best interests
at heart and those interests involve
convincing Belle to marry him so that he
can have what he believes he deserves
the best wife in town it's always fun
watching Luke Evans play the incredibly
arrogant but ultimately clueless Gaston
and I love the line he says that a foo
after he tells the crowd to leave I'm
not sure what's going on here but I'm
pretty sure I just fixed it however I
can see why the scene was cursed as it
doesn't add anything particularly new or
revelatory to what we learn and started
the movie about the characters of Belle
and Gaston and their attitude and
feelings towards one another the musical
number days in the Sun was a new song
introduced in the live-action movie
however there is an alternate version of
the song which begins with the beast
dreaming of his mother singing to him
when he was lying in bed as a young boy
in this alternate version the princes
mother sings the first part of the song
saying she'll never leave him until her
own life is done now the middle of this
deleted version is a same with in the
final film but at the end of the cut
version the princes mother has died in
her bed and her young son watches over
her until he's pulled away by his father
this original version had to be partly
reshot after it was discovered that test
audiences were mixing up actress Harriet
Jones he plays the princes mother with
Hattie Morahan who plays Agatha aka The
Enchantress because of this confusion
the scene has changed with Harriet
Jones's role cut back to a non singing
part where she just made dead in the bed
while the Prince looked on and in the
refilmed scene she also had dark rather
than blond hair to further differentiate
her from the character of enchantress
also the princess part was recast with a
young actor who could sing he now had to
sing the first few lines of the song as
it appears in the final film it's a real
shame the original version wasn't used
as actress Harriet Jones is such a
lovely singing voice and that version
packs an even stronger emotional punch
because the young prince's mother sings
to him that she'll never leave him but
by the end of the song she's dead and
he's asking why she left him plus the
alternate version gives at least one
real moment on-screen for the princes
mother whereas her time on-screen in the
final film was reduced to almost nothing
I feel like instead of altering this
scene they could have simply refilmed it
as it was but changing the colour of the
mother's hair to make the difference
from The Enchantress
even clearer so what do you think about
the deleted scenes and were there any
you think should have been in the movie
and which animated Disney film are you
most looking forward to seeing made into
a live-action movie next to enter the
giveaway for this gorgeous hardback book
tale as old as time the art and making a
Beauty and the Beast
make sure you're a subscriber and leave
a comment about the movie and also
answer the following questions what two
things does Belle give Agatha in the
deleted scene remember to turn on your
notifications to see all my new beauty
in the beasts videos and to find out if
you win the giveaway and if you enjoyed
this video don't forget to give it a
thumbs up and also check out more of my
Disney videos below thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers